الرضيع المعجزه او طفله الحبل السري قصه
العالم كله متابعها من اول يوم من لما
انولدت تحت الانقاض ولقيوها بعد ساعات جنب
جثه والدتها والحبل السري لسه مربوط فيها
ونقلوها على المستشفى بين الحياه والموت
وسمعنا انه كل افراد اسرتها ماتوا
واخبارها وصلت كل العالم والناس بتتساءل
عن مصيرها سمعنا انه طبيبها المعالج سماها
ايه وجالس براعيها هو وزوجته وسمعنا عن
عروض لتبنيها من مشاهير وغير مشاهير وصلت
لحد انه حتى في سمعنا اشاعه عن عرض النجمه
انجينا جولي انه تتبناها وسمعنا كمان عن
محاوله لخطفها من المستشفى كلها كانت
اخبار مقلقه ومزعجه لكن اليوم في خبر عن
الرضيعه مختلف وعلى الاقل يعني بيبسط
فالطفله اعلن انه خلاص انها بامان في حضن
عمتها واسرتها بعد ما خلصت اجراءات تبنيها
وتم اجراء فحص الحمض النووي للتاكد من
انها عمتها فعلا والعائله اسمها او اطلقت
عليها العمه والعيله اسم عفراء على اسم
والدتها الله يرحمها وكان
ظهر زوج عمتها خليل السوده هو حامل الطفل
عفراء على يده اليمين وبنته اللي انولدت
بعد الزلزال بثلاثه ايام على يد اليسار
وقال انه عفراء بتعني لهم كثير وانها ذكرى
من والدها عبد الله ووالدتها عفراء وانه
اتاخروا ياخذوها بسبب الاجراءات القانونيه
اي الطفله عفراقي اللي ولدت تحت الانقاض
كانت بالمشفى واليوم استلمناها والحمد لله
صحتها جيده
كان تاخير الاستلام في كان اجراءات
قانونيه يعني طلبت منه من المسؤولين في
المنطقه
وتاكدوا انه احنا قرايبها وسلطه قارب
الايه البنت عنا كتير يعني ما ظل من اهلها
غير هالطفله هاي وهاي راحت تبقى ذكرى يعني
عندي وعند عمتها وقرايبينا كلياتهم من
الضيعه راح تبقى يعني ذكرى من ابوها وامها
للقريه كلياته مو بس لالي يعني والعمته
[موسيقى]